mon espoir pour l'avenir est que l'
afghanistan redevienne un pays
stable, sûr et pacifique et
prospère dans le temps en termes de travail, d'
éducation et de santé
je vois la
campagne je vois différents endroits
j'explore
la région autour de moi
en attendant c'est l'exercice tu vois
la
forme physique du
vélo et je fais
1200 kilomètres par mois à vélo
c'est un
bon élément du vélo
[Musique
] tous les immigrants ne sont pas là juste pour
prendre  l'argent du gouvernement, donc
il y a beaucoup d'immigrants qu'ils font
un travail acharné, qu'ils donnent à l'impôt du pays
et aussi ils font des choses positives pour le
pays,
donc mon message
est
que beaucoup d'immigrants apporteront de bonnes
compétences avec eux  entendez
et ils participent
à cette société
[Musique]
vous